- [Leesa] Hi Andy, how are you?
- [Gary] When I say
my team I mean even this,
the blog that I do,
the content I put out,
I also come from the wine
business and so some of the
stuff we do to drive results
happens that world so I just
wanted him to sit in because if
he doesn't I'm not capable of
like follow-up.
- [Leesa] Okay.
(laughs) No, not
a problem at all.
- Alex is the same.
He does business
development on my team.
- [Leesa] Hi Alex.
- [Jason] Hey Alex. Jason.
- [Alex] Alex.
- [Gary] Since I'm giving Andy
so much he might not
be able to follow up soon.
- [Leesa] Nice to meet you.
- [Alex] Likewise.
- Cool.
So tell us about the biz.
- Sure.
So the concept of
The Eighth evolved from me
actually shopping in Barney's
and Bergdorf Men's for a really
cool, sexy, high-end
underwear for my husband.
He started GoldenTree Asset
Management which has $12 billion
of assets under management.
He's a Wall Street guy but he
likes to look pretty hot and all
that so I'm seeing nothing
for the Christmas/Hanukkah time
I thought there'd be
something kind of cool.
'Cause Victoria Secret always
has the million dollar bra.
- That's right.
- Something very hot and sexy.
- Yep.
- So I didn't
see anything there.
And then I went back for
Valentine's day and said
I'll get him something very hot
and sexy for Valentine's Day.
- [Gary] And
we're talking boxers?
- [Leesa] Yeah, I was
looking for boxers.
- [Gary] In theory?
- Yeah, boxers, maybe some silk.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- Some artwork, something.
- [Gary] Yeah, yeah.
Something cool.
- So nothing and I said, huh,
I wanna figure out if there's a
business here because
it seems like there's--
- [Gary] A demand.
- there's a need in the market.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- There's probably a need
for a business. Right?
- [Gary] Yeah, always.
- I met Jason and
Anna Beth's not here,
she apologizes.
- [Gary] No worries.
- But she's a former editor,
fashion editor at Vogue.
She was at Seventeen Magazine.
She has a whole
fashion/photography background.
- [Gary] Got it.
- Jason did the private label.
He's a designer.
He can make anything,
if you need something now,
he'll probably go
back and get it for you.
- Garment-wise.
- [Gary] Yeah.
Not like a pumpkin pie?
- [Jason] No.
- Okay.
- We can't cook. That
we can't, we can't cook.
- [Gary] Collectively,
as a unit.
- No.
- [Gary] Okay.
Got it, got it.
- We're not good cooks.
- Okay.
- [Leesa] Anyway,
so I researched it,
I researched
Calvin Klein basically had
97% of the market share for
men's underwear at a time when
I was looking at
what the market was.
Revenue's,
unbelievable worldwide.
- [Gary] This is
premium boxer category?
You know you would put it as?
Why Calvin had
such a big percentage.
- Right.
- [Jason] Mid-tier.
- [Gary] Mid-tier.
- Mid-tier but they were really
dominating the entire market.
So we talked about
things like I believe,
you know, I wear a lot of
Loro Piana and all of that so we
looked at the Logo Piana
cashmere which
Jason was able to source.
We retained and commissioned
artists like Richard Phillips,
David Torok people who do twill.
So we have people that
do twill, you would like this.
One twill, I don't know if you
can find it of famous athletes
in compromising positions like
Derek Jeter being
found caught in bed.
- [Gary] Yep.
- We have Larry Bird, who was on
the cover of Sports Illustrated
by accident looks like
two cheerleaders
giving him a blowjob.
- [Gary] Yep.
- [Leesa] Which they
retracted at one point.
Muhammad Ali, we did a
special because of his passing.
We have the number
eight buried all around.
So anyway, we came up
with some really cool things.
I don't know if
you have the cashmere.
We also came up
with compression shorts
that Equinox voted
number one in the country for
the best compression short while
you're working out.
- [Gary] Yep.
This is cool.
- This was picked up by Gorsach
which is the number one
store in Aspen and Vail.
- Feel great.
- [Jason] Feels good, yeah?
- Yeah.
- [Leesa] It's
like a baby's tush.
Anyway, Gorsach has a 3 million
reader subscription for their
catalog and all that
and Gorsach is in Vail.
- [Gary] What's
the price points?
- High.
- [Gary] Of course.
Well, that's what
you went out to do.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- So we do a
lot with The Eighth.
This is the 800.
We sell out every
time. He can't get it in.
We sell out all
the time at 800.
- These are 78, these are 68.
Opening price point is
about $48 for something solid.
Something like that.
- [Gary] Yep.
- We have the selfie, so if you
take a selfie of yourself in it,
which we hope people will
and put it on Instagram which
they have,--
- [Gary] Sure.
- this comes this way
and then it flips over.
So we have kinda
very cute and clever ideas
that our designers came up with.
We were at Art Basel,
we were featured at Art Basel.
- [Gary] How long has
the company been around?
- [Jason] Three years.
- Well, a year and a
half that we launched.
We were in concept and together,
incorporated
it's been about three.
- [Gary] Took you about
18 months to get to market.
- Yep.
- [Gary] Okay.
- So we had a launch party
at the Church Street Boxing Gym
with Travis Scott
who's a rapper.
- [Gary] Yep, yep.
- So we had him on the ropes
standing up with his waistband.
So we've had some
really great, great press.
GQ Magazine, Vanity Fair,--
- [Gary] And the business is
selling mainly through retail or
direct to consumer?
- We're really
good with website.
- [Gary] Got it.
- The website is on fire.
- So what percentage
of your business is--
- We'd love to show you guys,
maybe if we were in Colorado.
- Unless we don't smoke it.
- If you don't
smoke it, you're fine.
No, of course not.
- So this is a Richard fil--
- That's cool.
- This was
featured at Art Basel.
So it's a weed, if you're high,
because your eyes get a certain
retina whatever
he told me, you see
this the weed pops
out while you're high.
Whatever.
I wouldn't know.
So they say.
- What percentage of the
business is direct
to consumer versus--
- I'd say about 80%.
- Direct to consumer?
- That has been our
focus from the beginning.
- Of course, keep the margin.
- And also engage the customer.
We go to any, Bergdorf's wants
something like this but then
they may not necessarily go--
- Sure.
- then you kind
of dilute the brand.
- Of course.
- And what it looks
like so we like to be able--
- And how are you
driving sales to dot-com?
Press mainly so far?
- In the beginning it
was sort of organic press.
- Yeah.
- A little bit of reach
out to different publications.
- Yep.
- Sort of the old school method.
- We also are featured in many,
I have a big movie background so
they're featured in movies.
Alec Baldwin, De Niro in various
movies that have come out and
premiered so we
try to use various--
- Product placement.
- Projects and all of that.
And we have some SEO,
some online research
and all that that we target.
- SEO or SEM?
- SEO.
- SEM. And any Facebook?
- Facebook's it's not as active.
- Yeah.
- But you're not
running Facebook ads?
- They were, yeah.
The SEO agency.
- Got it.
And Instagram or
influencers on Instagram?
- We have.
Instagram's been
pretty good to us.
- Yep.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, we have all of that.
- But neither, you don't have an
internal asset that
understands digital marketing?
- No.
- So you're at the mercy--
- That's where
we're at right now.
So we're trying to
say this has worked.
This has been a good
place for us and now that we're
established we know
what our best sellers are.
We know how we want to
build the product going forward.
You know, what's next.
And I think we've created a
vocabulary for the brand and a
sort of culture on what
we do and how we do things.
It's not typical of other
brands out there right now.
So it's what we can present to
kind of move
forward with the brand.
- [Gary] You need to have an
internal resource for digital
marketing if you're going to
be a direct to consumer brand.
- Okay.
- [Gary] First and foremost.
From like a
religion over tactics,--
- Okay.
- [Gary] That's the first
religious thing you have to do.
- Okay.
- [Gary] Otherwise you're at
the mercy of an SEO firm that is
probably doing Facebook terribly
wrong even though Facebook...
SEO's easier to
show black and white,
and is a 20-year practice.
So anybody can
do SEO, kinda thing,
versus most
people can't do Facebook.
But all the action is
on Facebook and Instagram
especially for a visual brand.
- [Jason] Mhmmm.
- You're a visual brand.
- [Jason] Yeah.
- Google, fine, somebody
searches boxers or what have you
and you can win that
game but it's blue letters.
If you really understood, if
you really gave a shit enough to
really understand
what's happening in Google,
it's completely the antithesis
of what you're building.
It's completely
commoditized branding.
- That's interesting.
- [Gary] Sure whereas Instagram
and Facebook are visual.
- Absolutely.
- Your blue letters are the same
as blue letters of like private
label, the least expensive
boxers in the world look exactly
like you on Google.
- [Jason] Right.
- Google blue letters.
- That's interesting.
- So, not only is there
ways to do it better
it's also a detriment to your
positioning and
all the effort you're
putting into it to most of
and then think about 80% of your
business is done online.
- Right.
- And I have to assume an
unbelievable proportion of the
traffic coming in outside of
like a good article in a search
term is gonna be the SEM.
- [Jason] Right.
- [Gary] So that's super
important to me and so I think
the follow-up to this is gonna
be how much do you want to pay
for somebody and then I'll
try to help get you the best
possible person for
the lowest possible,
you know kind of thing.
- [Leesa] That's fantastic.
- I think that's the
big, big, big take away.
So what you guys
want to happen that,
obviously you want to build
the biggest brand in the world.
- [Jason] Right.
- And view that is happening
through your
direct to consumer world.
Are you guys
thinking long term of
having your own
retail experiences?
Like how are you
thinking about distribution?
- [Jason] I think our
own retail experience.
- [Gary] Got it.
- [Leesa] Yep.
- So the same world Victoria's
Secret was able to create--
- [Gary] Would
that be in New York,
the first store?
I'm asking pretty specific
reason because I want to give
you the strategy
against the creative social.
If the answer is yes and
because you're not gonna spend
$1 million a year in
Facebook ads or maybe you are,
but I'm making some assumptions,
I want to localize the strategy
against the place
that you're most likely
gonna open the store.
- [Jason] Mhmmm.
- [Leesa] I guess
because we're New York based,
The Eighth came from 8th Avenue.
That's where we started so
it would be kind of apropos to
start in New York.
- On 8th Avenue, maybe even.
Okay.
- [Leesa] I would
think so, right?
- [Jason] Yeah.
- [Leesa] Absolutely.
- Okay. What else going,
obviously going into I had just
only met your husband so I don't
how much context you have,
was there anything that you guys
had coming in mentally into this
meeting questions or thoughts or
anything you
wanted me to talk about?
- [Leesa] I guess what we
were thinking about is whether
we should, and this is just
a question that I have,--
- Yeah.
- do we stay and do more
of the same 'cause it's good?
Do we start expanding?
And, you know,
it's weird because
we have a lot of women
who are wearing this.
We have a lot of
women, we gear only to men.
- Makes sense. Right.
- [Leesa] If you go
on our website it's men,
but we have a lot of women.
I don't know if
we're supposed to--
- How much
revenue do you guys have?
- I'd have to look that up.
I'm not the money person.
- No worries.
But it's new, it's
not that crazy yet.
- [Leesa] Yes. It's not that
crazy but we're always
looking to see
what we expand.
- The reason I ask that question
off of your rant is my intuition
is it's a common thing,
this is one man's point of view,
you'll get some different
points of view on this.
- [Jason] Mhmmm.
- I think people
go too wide too early.
- [Jason] Right.
- [Leesa] Stay with a
good thing, you're saying.
- I mean, look, you guys
are a team of quality and taste.
- [Leesa] For sure.
- You haven't even begun to
go down the path of
sales and conversion.
- [Leesa] Right.
- [Jason] Right.
- Right?
Everybody has their
strengths and weaknesses, right?
I think you guys are a game
of quality and taste and the
reality is that makes you
an artist and what makes you a
business is sales and conversion
and the cool thing is
you've outsourced that.
Now who's the
agency you guys went with?
- [Jason] For the SEO?
- Mhmmm.
- [Jason] Sprite house.
- I'm not, I don't
know who that is.
Did you have a relationship
with them or you guys met
with a bunch of people?
Or how did you come about?
- [Jason] It was through
a contact through the industry.
- Got it.
Yeah, that's to me, how
much are you spending with them?
- Their fees are, I believe,
they were $10,000 a month but
then you have to
pay for the advertising.
- Mhmmm.
- It's gonna be like
$20,000 a month for advertising.
- Yeah, if you're truly
spending $30,000 a month,
I have some great news.
You could do some real damage.
- [Jason] Mhmmm.
- I'd like to not spend $30,000
a month then
still do damage but--
- Well, of course.
I mean look, by the way,
you can still do damage with $1.
- [Leesa] Yeah.
- It's not gonna be the greatest
damage in the world but...
- [Leesa] Right. I'm
just saying, you know.
- Here's the good part.
You're already spending enough
money to see meaningful results
and I don't know
if you are or not,
do you have any feel of what
you're doing in
revenue per month?
Through the e-com channel?
- [Leesa] I would
have to look it up.
I don't go through the account.
No, the answer is I
wasn't prepared for that. Sorry.
- That's okay.
That's okay.
But to that point, are you guys,
I still think that that brings
some interesting intrigue to
the conversation
around art and science.
Somebody's got to be
grounded in that shit.
- [Leesa] Right.
- And it can't
be your accountant.
- [Leesa] Right.
- Somebody's got to
be running the business.
- [Leesa] Right, I'm basically
running the business,--
- And by the way,
I'm run the business,
I run this business,
it's $100 million business,
I don't know shit about numbers.
I have people do it
but I'm grounded in them.
- [Leesa] Right.
- Because you have to
have them for strategy.
- [Leesa] Right.
- [Jason] Right.
- You know what I mean?
- [Leesa] Yeah.
I'm focusing on
going forward and sales--
- By the way, you should
focus on what you do best.
- [Leesa] Right,
that's what I'm focusing on.
I'm not really retrospective
to see how much are we making,
how much are we making?
It's more like, where do we go?
What could we do?
How could we do it better?
- I'm less worried
about how much you're making,
I'm worried about what your
money's being spent on to make
what you want to happen.
- [Leesa] Gotcha.
- When you're spending
$360,000 a year in advertising,
I can have all of
Manhattan giving a fuck.
- [Leesa] Right. Right.
- And you don't have that.
- [Leesa] No.
For sure, no.
- Correct.
- [Jason] Correct.
- So what I think you have is
2004 digital marketers who are
making a margin on
you and that's why--
- [Leesa] That's
why I've stopped them.
I stopped them as
of August I believe.
- [Jason] Right.
- Got it.
- [Leesa] I stopped,
I said bye-bye.
- Got it.
- [Leesa] Thanks but no thanks.
'Cause it's a tremendous
amount of money and
it's just not
yielding the results.
I know it could possibly in the
future but you got to justify
every month so the
answer is I stopped that.
- Got it.
- [Leesa] I'm looking, I am
looking for a way like you're
saying, what makes sense
dollar wise to get this going.
You know?
- I think it's Instagram,
I think it's Snapchat,
I think it's Facebook,
I think it's YouTube.
I think it's where the
consumer's attention is.
- [Leesa] So you think
it's not a specific company.
You're saying someone in our,
to hire somebody
to sit in our offices.
- My intuition is
it ends up being both.
- [Leesa] Okay.
- But think about it.
It's like me paying for art.
It's not what I do and
if I'm the decision maker,
I need you to be
my partner to be like,
"Is he right?"
I want you guys,
at least on paper,
I want you have somebody
to know if we're the best,
if Rick's the best,
if Sally's the best.
You guys don't have the
background for judge and jury.
- [Leesa] Of course.
- You have taste, you
know if this is a good...
If you asked me to know
what the fuck this should cost,
I'd be dead.
- [Jason] Right.
- You know that in your sleep.
- [Leesa] Of course.
- I want you to have that asset
on your team so when all the
characters like me come around--
- [Jason] Won't be asking about
all the abbreviations, yeah.
- They know what they hell
they're talking about so yes.
- [Leesa] Right.
- I think that's important and
I think the other thing that's
running through my mind is a lot
of people that work for me want
to work in small companies and
they come here for training and
so I might be able to help with
somebody who's young which will
cost you less but skill above
their age and can do it all.
Creative and you know?
- [Leesa] No,
that would be ideal.
- Can I ask you
a crazy question?
Have you thought
about building your brand?
- [Leesa] Have I
thought about it?
Of course.
I dream about it.
- I think that is
the biggest wildcard.
So I think you should do all
that but if you ask me how it
becomes big, it's
because you became big.
And in the same way
what he's doing right now,
there's a new way to become big.
- [Jason] Right.
- I actually think--
- I don't know that.
I'm not from that.
- I'm aware.
- I'm too old for that.
- I understand and by the
way this is not an age thing.
What we're inventing...
Just so you know.
- There's a young-ness for it.
- No, no, they can
all attest to this.
All the 20-year-olds in the
world don't understand
what I'm talking about.
I'm talking about the modern day
human production
company around a person.
There's no
20-year-old running around.
They understand
how to take a selfie.
They understand that
Snapchat's important.
They don't understand the
science that the 15 people
sitting out here that all work
on just my brand understand.
- [Leesa] But you do.
- I do and so do they and
they'll go on to either crush
with me or it will be known
because once somebody figures
something out
the world will know.
- [Leesa] Right.
- But I sure do.
Basically what I know right now
is we're sitting on a capability
that is what
reality TV was in 2000.
- [Jason] Sure.
- And once in a
while you come across
a person who actually can
play, it still takes talent.
- [Leesa] Right.
- My early intuition on you
is that you have that thing and
you need to debate it.
- Right, I feel
like I have the talent.
I'm not the talent but they're
the talent and I feel like they
have the product and they have
the quality and then I feel like
it's my job and my
wish to get it out there.
- I think the way I kind of
think about it is if tomorrow
Bravo came to you guys and said,
"Do you want to do a show about
"your journey in
building this company?"
You would seriously consider it
and I mean I don't know you like
how you're wired like fuck that
or that's great but you would
seriously consider it for the
exposure for what it would do
for your business and I think
you would do
really well in that show.
And I think when I see that,
you need to get grounded in what
vlogging is and all this stuff.
- [Leesa] What what is?
- Vlogging, video blogging.
- [Leesa] Okay.
It's basically
a reality TV show.
Like I'm not joking when
I tell you that if you ask me
push comes to shove to be
historically correct on the
thing that made
your business big,
it would be a human being
following you around with a
camera every day.
- [Leesa] Huh.
Okay.
That's interesting.
- Yeah.
I'm so interested in it that
we've been spending the
last six months, in about three
months we're gonna launch
something called VaynerTalent so
I've been talking to Tyra Banks and
Curtis Martin, football player,
a bunch of different people.
We have figured out something
for me in the last six months
and I've been on social media
and producing
content for a decade.
- [Jason] Right.
- But in the last
six months, last year,
we've really figured it out.
And now we're trying to figure
out if we can scale it as a,
it's just it's funny to me that
that $20,000 a month charging
somebody for something like
this would bring them a lot more
business than what we do best in
the world here on Facebook and
Instagram creative and ads.
- [Jason] Hmmm.
- It's cool. It's just
how the world works.
- [Leesa] I think
it's unbelievable.
- So, something
you should sleep on.
I don't necessarily need you as
a client but I could show you
how it's done and you can hire
it internally but it's obviously
a very personal decision.
- [Leesa] Right.
- Like, I'm not joking.
I mean a reality show.
- [Leesa] Right.
- Like there is a man or a woman
for that matter that follows you
around and you yelling
at Liana, it's you shopping,
it's your meetings.
It's you having
business meetings.
It's a show and it airs
on Facebook and YouTube and
I believe it would be the
biggest gateway drug to the
growth of your business.
- [Leesa] Wow.
- [Jason] Everybody
wants to see your pants.
(group laughter)
- But I think it's very easy
thing to understand today if you
think about Skinny Girl or
if you think about the
Kardashian phenomenon
or the fact the
DJ Khaled's gonna
make $30 to 40 million.
- [Leesa] So what is it
everyone's a voyeur?
- Yeah.
- [Leesa] Like what is it?
People want to get a
sneak peek of what you're doing?
- No, people are, the
psychological punchline?
- [Leesa] Yeah. Yes.
- Rubbernecking.
- [Jason] Okay.
- [Leesa] I see
what you're saying.
- It's just a deep
inherent human thing.
It's called yenta syndrome.
- [Leesa] Yenta syndrome.
- Got it?
- [Leesa] I've got it.
- It's just who we are.
- [Leesa] Right.
- It's what people are.
- [Jason] Yeah.
- [Leesa] Right.
- We're generally
interested in people.
- [Leesa] And they
want to see catastrophes?
- No, they just
want to see the truth.
- [Leesa] Want to see the truth.
- Got it?
That's why what I'm doing
is gonna beat reality TV 'cause
reality is just more of the
truth of TV but this is way more
truth than reality TV.
- [Leesa] And where do you--
- Distribution?
Facebook and YouTube but
then think about what you do.
What people don't know is so
now we take $1000 and we run the
ads, so we run, nobody
knows who the fuck you are.
- [Leesa] Sure.
- Here's episode one of you.
No one gives a shit.
- [Leesa] Right.
- But Facebook is the best ad
product in the world so you post
it and then we run
$1,000 worth of ads against
the employees of
Saks Fifth Avenue,
Barneys and Nordstrom's.
So now if I'm Sally on the
Upper West Side and I work at
Nordstrom's when I'm going
through my Facebook feed and
seeing my friend's daughter,
I'm gonna see episode
one of your show in my feed.
94 out of 100 are gonna be like
I don't give a fuck but six are
gonna watch it and day after
day after day depending on how
interesting and clever and how
well it's edited and how well
the ads are targeted
you build. That's it.
- [Leesa] And how long are they?
These little episodes.
- They run the gamut.
DRock's laughing because we're
airing on Monday an hour and
30 minute version of it
but normally ours runs,
mine runs 10 to 25.
We've got our first beta outside
of me a graffiti artist and
motivational speaker,
how long have those been?
- [Andy] 20 minutes.
- 20 minutes.
- [Andy] Varies but...
- And so do you have
your own Facebook Page?
- Yes.
- Just for the?
- [Andy] For you.
- For the video?
- Yes.
- Everything
under your business?
- That's a very good point.
In the first meeting--
- And you're
wearing the wrong underwear.
- Clearly.
- I've got to
pull your shirt down.
- I got it.
- I'm getting up.
- I got it, I'm sorry.
- Send him some
underwear. (laughs)
- So the punchline is--
- Just joking.
- I know you were.
But I love being respectful.
We have a strategy
session at first.
There's a very good debate to
it being either your page or
the company's page
and we would talk.
You'll see in the deck we're
making for people the first
thing it says is we're
reverse engineering you.
- [Jason] Hmmm.
- You can be the most
famous person in the world
and be an introvert.
It means we're
not working together.
- [Leesa] Right.
- You may be so famous that
you don't want to do it anymore.
- [Jason] Right.
- You've got to
be the right person.
- [Leesa and Jason] Right.
- I have no time.
Time is a factor.
I don't show my children.
- [Leesa] Right.
- Just a decision
my wife and I made.
- [Leesa] Right.
- I wish I did.
- Because it'd be
even more viral. You know?
(group laughter)
But that's something
that's important to us.
- [Leesa] Right.
- [DRock] (inaudible)
is showing his family.
- Right, which is
huge. Family kills.
Like I'm leaving
millions of views on the table.
Especially with
my two characters.
- Kids and probably puppies.
- Yeah, everybody
plays their own thing, right?
As you can imagine I do a lot of
business so a lot of stuff never
makes it 'cause I'm
having, I'm firing somebody,
I'm talking about
somebody's salary.
We're negotiating things that TV
shows that are six months away
that nobody can know
about so you live life.
- [Leesa] Is he
always filming you?
Whatever you're doing?
- Yes, I mean some
people ask for him not to.
Sometimes I feel
uncomfortable in the scenario.
- [Leesa] What's he at home?
- No.
- [Leesa] So it's just here?
- Yeah, it's my business life.
- [Leesa] Right, okay.
- It's not just here.
It's in Finland,
it's Orlando, yeah, yeah.
- [Leesa] You're working.
- Yeah.
- [Jason] The
sitcom focuses on that.
- That's right.
- [Jason] The office.
- It's a business show.
It's my entrepreneurial life.
I reference my family.
- [Leesa] Right.
- But I just have a funny
feeling you've got some upside
in that and it's
something you should,
two minutes and
you should sleep on it.
- [Leesa] Okay.
- [Jason] You're
right about that.
Your intuition is
right. (inaudible)
- [Gary] I think so.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] It's just,
I almost feel like I see
life in a different lens.
When I see it I just know and
the truth is unlike learning the
craft of how
much does this cost,
learning the craft of
what these 800 people do,
what's so great about it
and you're gonna know this,
you just do you.
- [Leesa] Right. That's easy.
I do me all the time.
- It's the easiest thing to do
in life so
something to think about.
Something to think about.
- [Leesa] So would you
be that the person
would be in the office--
- Everywhere.
- or following him home?
- [Jason] No, you.
- And by the way, by the way,
it could be only about you and
you're a side character.
It could be the show about the
whole business and there could
be four characters.
It could be "Cheers."
- [Leesa] Yeah.
"Sex In The City?"
- That's right.
It could be anything that
you want it to be because here's
what's better than
signing a deal with Bravo,
you're in control
of the final edit.
- [Leesa] Right.
- [Jason] Right.
- [Leesa] That's good.
- Yeah, that's
where it gets real good.
Now, the thing is I would
recommend that if you try to
micromanage too much and not
listen to what we know which is
you have to show vulnerability,
you have to show real humanity.
Like you have to show the
shit you don't want to show.
- [Leesa] Right.
- Otherwise nobody gives a
fuck 'cause you're
back to television.
- [Leesa] Right.
- Got it?
- [Leesa] Yeah. Got it.
- Something to debate.
So I think those are the
two things you
should be sleeping on.
A, a real digital strategy
for 2017 not for 2006 and
B, a real conversation amongst
yourselves of like is this the
right model and this is a model
that literally exists only with
people that film themselves,
vloggers on YouTube
that have transcended.
I'm not good at that so I made
my own version of it which is
this but it's real.
We know that and
then the truth is--
- [Leesa] All equally,
it's Facebook, Instagram,
Snapchat, are they
all equally powerful?
Do you do them all?
- I do them all.
- [Leesa] You put the
same content on everything.
- Nope.
- [Leesa] You blast it?
- [Leesa] No?
- Because most people use
social media to blast out,
you have to create for it.
So content that works on
Snapchat is me
first person always.
Whereas YouTube and Facebook is
the distribution
of the show, got it?
Instagram is me but I use that
for motivational quotes mainly.
You know so duh-duh-duh-duh-duh.
All strategy like the thing that
people don't understand is this
is the world, this is the actual
world of communication and
there's real skill and
everybody thinks it's just like,
"Oh, it's social media."
- [Leesa] Right.
It's exponentially harder
than print like if your lovely
partner was here I would
absolutely make her feel
inferior to the
skill she deployed against
Sprink 'cause it was easier.
- [Leesa] Right.
- [Jason] Yeah, we know.
- [Leesa] Right, no question.
- It's just easier.
- [Leesa] Right.
- I don't know,
it's not her fault.
- [Leesa] Right.
- It's just the truth.
Like this is very complex,
nuanced and detailed which is
why everybody
thinks it's, first of all,
everybody doesn't
think it's a big deal.
And then when they spend on it
and they aren't successful they
don't think it works.
It works, you didn't
know what to do with it.
You know how much money
I would make playing a piano?
(clicks tongue)
(group laughter)
You know what I mean?
- [Leesa] Right.
- But Billy Joel
makes fucking billions.
- [Leesa] Right.
- You have to know
what the fuck you're doing.
- [Leesa] Right.
- So...
- [Leesa] Great.
- [Jason] Cool.
- Alright, good.
- [Leesa] Really
appreciate this.
- Send me an email and let me
know if there's
anything I can help with.
- [Leesa] Absolutely.
- Real pleasure, take care.
Thanks for hanging guys.
- [Alex] Nice meeting you.
- [Leesa] Really great.
- But you could really, out,
going cliche and I don't really
know you but I'm just
giving you look like you could
win the "Housewives,"
"Sex In The City"
thing in a real way.
I'm telling you
right now you could.
You have to think about it.
- [Leesa] Right.
And would you help with that?
- I don't wanna, here's
what I can promise you.
I can promise you you can
come in here and sit with me and
Lindsay and I'll walk you
through what VaynerTalent is.
I'm still working, you know
what makes a great salesperson,
somebody that really
believes in their shit.
- [Jason] Mhmmm.
- [Leesa] Right.
- I know we've got it.
I really believe in it.
I'm scared of two things.
One, that's why I'm beta
testing with this one person.
I really want to triple check
because I want everyone talking
about me behind
my back the best.
- [Leesa] Right.
- Because I make five times
$20,000 a month to give a speech
I'll do that. It's
not about the money.
I want to build something
eventually that could be worth
billions because that's
what production companies are.
- [Leesa] Of course.
- And two, I need to know you
better because I have a lot of
empathy for what it takes.
What they'll tell you
is for all my intensity
I let the creators
do their thing.
I don't control the message.
- [Leesa] Right.
- And I've been in this for 10
years understanding this world.
Here I just do a whole new
thing for you to think about.
- [Leesa] Right.
- You never thought about it.
- [Leesa] Never
thought about it.
- Now you're gonna think about
it and even if you say yes 100%
I have so much empathy for you
wanting to be very in control of
the final output and in that is
a lack of speed which is the
ROI of the whole thing.
- [Jason] Right.
So I need you to be in the no
business not the yes business.
What I mean by
that is you sit down
you watch for
23 minutes and you're like,
"No, that one thing I can't
like my sister will kill me."
- [Leesa] Right.
- Not--
- [Leesa] I've been
thinking about that
Leon will kill me,
my daughter will kill me.
I have a lot of people
who could kill me.
- Right. Not, ooh,
I don't like that angle.
- [Leesa] Right.
- You're just gonna lose.
- [Leesa] That's not it, it's...
- Most of all, yourself.
- Yep, yep.
- By the way,
getting into a place where
people are stopping you.
I'm getting stopped 10,
15 times a day in the street.
It's changing my life.
You know I'm with my daughter
and fans are yelling out and
she's like, "Daddy." You know?
And by the way, people
like you and I, we want it.
- But you got to be
careful of the kids.
- You're in a different,
you're in a much
yeah, you're in a much,
that's correct.
You're in a different
place but I will tell you this.
You will sell shit.
I built a $100 million
business on my brand.
You'll sell shit.
- Right.
- Well that's the bottom line.
I tell him that
sales are the bottom line.
- You will get an email from QVC
saying do you
want to work with us?
You will get an email from for
an unbelievable shop in Naples,
Florida that has four
locations that says we love you
we watch you every day.
We want your product,
would you come to the store?
You'll get an email from
Harper Collins offering
you $100,000 to write a book.
It will happen.
That fucking $30,000 a month
deployed against this for
one year, that $360,000
will pay you back millions.
This is the new world.
- I love that.
I love that.
- [Jason] Cool.
- Cool.
- Really excited.
- Thanks a lot, Gary.
- Take care guys. Yeah.
Stay well, bye-bye.
You really think this
is right for her, huh?
I'm going off your vibe now.
- [Jason] I'm saying
with even like...
just from that one conversation.
(crosstalk)
- But through Leo even with our
nightlife of meeting Hillary,
doing all these things.
- [Gary] By the way,
somethings you can and
somethings you can't.
You know what I mean?
I was with
Joe Biden two days ago.
We didn't film that.
- Right, right.
- [Gary] But you push
for as much as you can.
- Right, sometimes
it spills over, you know.
- [Gary] Yeah.
Alright, take care.
- Bye.
- [Gary] Bye-bye, take care.